my name is Gerald I'm a doctor from
Ireland today I'm taking part in my
first tournament of inclusive rugby the
Irish gave rugby team with over 45 teams
of LGBT men and women from all over the
European continents when I decided to
join the Emerald warriors I was at a
very low point in my life I had been
suffering with depression growing up in
Ireland in the late 80s and early 90s
homosexuality was still a crime it led
to internalize feelings of being wrong
being around the Warriors has just
helped me to accept myself more and also
accept my place in the world around me
my family is delighted that I favorite
they're a great source of strength in
this
[Applause]
I love for children they've all been
born equal years ago you could never say
who you really we're and it's a I think
Ireland just so much better place but
it's taken a while to get us here
when it came to the Feist for marriage
equality the Irish population the first
one in the entire world by popular vote
said that yes they felt those people
like me aren't really different from
anybody else and that we do have a place
in society and that our loves and our
relationships aren't any worse than
anybody else's married in Ireland we got
married two years after the same
separate referendum and I went my
husband now 10 years this is my son his
name is Jake and he's almost 2 years of
age where our life changed when he came
into our world he keeps us on her toes
as you can see would you like some
treats how you see myself as a rugby
player as a father and my sexual
orientation happens to be homosexual
that's how is it sexist most homophobic
to her name get some or learn some
Christ mist on D 1602 per dear presume
it's a professional impression bjork and
then we are anspaugh's peon there yeah
was hard to suffocate it's awful to
think that there are places where teams
like mine can't exist boss I'm hopeful
for the future change does happen and
most of the time is good
[Applause]
[Music]